qué significa esta declaración de
emergencia de salud global y qué
implicaciones tiene
básicamente significa en que hay un
brote nuevo de esta enfermedad que está
afectando a los diferentes continentes y
la medida que toma las denuncias de la
salud permite que los países bien a
tomar medidas y recomendaciones acorde a
la naturaleza en cada país de la
transmisión es decir sabemos que por
ejemplo el continente europeo tiene un
alto riesgo en este momento los otros
países en los diferentes continentes
incluyendo américa latina que considera
que tiene un riesgo mol dado e implica
que aquí el país de los cuales ya hay
transmisión o por mejor se han detectado
personas que quieran contagiado y alguna
licencia tiene transmisión local pues
tiene que tomar las medidas para evitar
la discriminación es decir hacer una
estrategia de contención y proteger a
las personas vulnerables lo que es estas
medidas que se toman van a permitir que
cada país pues tenga una estrategia y un
plan de trabajo para lograr evitar que
haya una mayor diseminación de esta
epidemia
carlos lado ms insistió hoy en que la
mayoría de contagios se están dando por
contactos sexuales entre hombres
homosexuales y que además tienen varias
parejas a lo largo del tiempo como se
explica esto versus por ejemplo el
contagio en niños y cómo se puede
interpretar para no caer en
discriminación
y yo creo es una pregunta extremadamente
importante para tenerlo presente
efectivamente la eliminación de esta de
este brote inició en población de
hombres que tiene sexo con hombres y que
tienen alguna de varias parejas y eso
hace que la madre la concentración en
este momento de la epidemia en
diferentes países se ha concentrado en
este en esta población esto no significa
que sea la única por lo simple pueda ser
afectada lo que significa que en este
momento de la epidemia está concentrada
en este grupo poblacional pero si no se
logra hacer una contención es posible
que empiece a afectar a otras
poblaciones vulnerables
específicamente personas
inmunocomprometidas y niños que son una
población que tendrán mayor riesgo de
complicación por esto es importante que
la población que tiene exceso de hombres
que tienen sexo con hombres puede que
tenga en cuenta que está circulando el
virus terminan medidas de prevención
también la por los países hay aún al
llamado
a las comunidades para que justamente se
haya una diferencia en la forma como se
transmite la educación y ahí viene el
riesgo que existe en este momento pero
claramente es también importante
resaltar que ésta no es una enfermedad
no netamente de contacto sexual por
ahora es una persona que ha tenido este
impacto pero no es no solamente de esta
manera que se transmite como ya lo hemos
visto porque hay personas trabajador de
la salud e incluso algún dios que ya se
han contagiado y en ese sentido hay que
tenerlo presente en la en el riesgo que
puede sentir para la población general
mire rápidamente se sabe porque la
población homosexual en este momento es
considerada más vulnerable a la viruela
del mono y a partir de esta declaratoria
también le pregunto si aumentará la
producción de vacunas o incluso de una
vacuna propia para la viruela del mono
dos cosas la primera es
que son efectivas y básicamente lo que
se está haciendo en este momento es
aumentar la producción para poder tener
la vacuna disponible para los grupos
vulnerables clic la mayor riesgo alan de
las personas homosexuales básicamente
está dada más que por la por la por la
misma conducta y por la forma como se ha
empezado este brote
sabemos que inició en
grupos de riesgo
de estas personas en europa y esto hace
que por eso está principalmente centrada
en esta población pero no es una
condición es de cinco años sino
sencillamente hasta el momento de una
enormidad de policastro sexual entre
personas que tienen
las contagiadas por la violaba cívica